la british ou do axé pas mille sacs
on arrivait sur un village doivent être
superbe
c'est ce que tu veux qu'on peut manquer
échos
arrêtant le soleil brille
si peut longer le relief à droite
trouvent qu'elle est du groupe fondre
apparaître la vallée derrière bâtiment
pas dire on va tout de même tout l'air
dans le jeu voire légale face aux
toulousains
et après
rdv gros plant d'arbre parce que ça
c'est super bas contre attend qu'on soit
les yeux pour ça on est à on est à 3
passe à 30 %
bon c'est pas très ferme
on va aller vers celui qui était bien
vingt et un peu à droite
elle son client voilà il est où est
juste devant là que la crevette au
dessus de leurs plus belles ouais on va
voir c'est pas top mais ouais m
sur le fond martine aubry si communauté
il faudra en trouver est ce que cette
crêperie